le conseil scientifique qui préconise de
ton confinement à la proche des fêtes
jean castex a suggéré hier aux français
de ne pas envoyer leurs enfants à
l'école jeudi et vendredi afin de
limiter le risque de contamination à
noël des propos qui contredisent le
gouvernement qui avait expliqué ces
derniers mois que les enfants étaient
peu contaminants justifiant ainsi
l'ouverture des écoles des propos qui
ont fait réagir le collectif des stylos
rouges on écoute le professeur de l'air
de l'être
arno fabre administrateur national du
mouvement sur la question sanitaire mais
sur d'autres aussi sur la question des
salaires sur la question des conditions
de travail et des conditions d'études
le problème c'est qu'on est abandonné
depuis très longtemps et on est
abandonnés parce qu'on a à faire
principalement que jean michel blanquer
à des ministres successifs qui mentent
comment peut-on croire que dans une
salle de 30 mètres carrés 35 mètres
carrés avec 30 élèves
le virus ne circule pas et donc tout a
été fait pour maintenir les écoles
ouvertes alors que malheureusement il
aurait fallu mettre en place très
rapidement dès septembre les 2000 groupe
les deux migros qui pouvaient ceux qui
se sont mis en place dans quelques
lycées parce qu'on nous dise effet au
lycée mais c'est pas vrai s'est fait
dans quelques lycées généraux ou alors
on est face à des évidences et
malheureusement on a des dirigeants
politiques qui lui nous abandonnent
parce que sur des questions évidentes
comme sur le fait que les profs prendre
soin mal payés on nous explique à banon
71% des profs n'auront aucune
augmentation que les autres auront 30
euros voilà on a affaire à des gens qui
sont irresponsables parce qu'en fait ils
véritablement il condamne les mois qui
viennent et les années qui viennent